The 2001 comedy Zoolander features an array
of Hollywood celebs in its cast.
Besides core stars like Ben Stiller, Owen
Wilson, and Will Ferrell, the movie boasts
appearances by actors like Judah Friedlander,
Alexander Skarsgård, and Andy Dick, among
many other famous faces.
But chances are you may have missed one major
celebrity who was hiding in plain sight.
After Stiller's model character Derek Zoolander
is captured by villain Mugatu's evil team,
henchman Katinka, played by real-life supermodel
Milla Jovovich, signals to a DJ to start the
brainwashing process.
The performer, donning dreadlocks, a stub
of a beard on his chin, and a nasty-looking
facial scar, puts down a record and starts
playing a remix of "Relax" by the popular
'80s band Frankie Goes To Hollywood.
The gold-toothed baddie also memorably fights
Wilson's Hansel in a breakdancing battle,
because, why not?
But just who was the man portraying the devious
disc jockey?
None other than actor Justin Theroux!
Yep, the guy who starred in the HBO drama
The Leftovers played the character "Evil DJ."
And apparently those breakdancing moves were
all his.
Theroux told TV host Conan O'Brien in September
2014:
"Yes, I learned when I was around, I don't
know, 12 or 13, somewhere in there, how to
breakdance…
And I had a little crew that we used to roll
around Washington, D.C."
Stiller apparently decided to make use of
Theroux's skills for Zoolander after seeing
him breakdance at his wedding to actress Christine
Taylor.
Theroux later reprised the character of Evil
DJ for the comedy's 2016 sequel, Zoolander
2, the screenplay for which he also helped
write with Stiller, Nicholas Stoller, and
John Hamburg.
"Relax."
He also dressed as Evil DJ on the red carpet
for the premiere of the second film, posing
for cameras in a white New York Yankees hoodie
and gold sneakers, as reported by Hello!
Magazine.
"How's the family reunion going?"
"Great.
I'd like to check him out for a few hours,
if that's okay."
"Sure, long as he's back by sundown."
Regarding working on Zoolander 2 with Stiller,
Theroux told Business Insider in 2016:
"I think we were all like, let's not try to
beat the first one, let's not think about
it like that.
Let's think about where the characters would
be historically 10 years later and see if
there's a funny idea of them being aged out."
He continued:
"We basically decided to run right at the
fact that, yeah, they are older, instead of
trying to pick up the movie one day after
or one week later.
We thought it would be funny if they were
washed up and had to come back into the industry."
His role in Zoolander and Zoolander 2 aside,
Theroux has made a name for himself on the
small and big screens with projects like Maniac,
The Girl on the Train, and On the Basis of
Sex.
Not only an actor, he's also a writer, lending
his talents to the 2008 comedy Tropic Thunder
and the 2010 Marvel movie Iron Man 2.
Despite his long list of film and TV gigs,
fans of celebrity news may know him best for
his relationship with movie star and Friends
alum Jennifer Aniston.
As noted by Cosmopolitan magazine, Theroux
and Aniston were first thought to have gotten
together in May 2011, and, before long, the
two reportedly moved in together.
By August 2012, Theroux had proposed to his
lady love, and the celebrity couple tied the
knot in August 2015.
Unfortunately, Theroux and Aniston wouldn't
remain together.
On Feb. 15, 2018, they announced that they
had separated, saying, in a joint statement
reported by Us Weekly:
"We are two best friends who have decided
to part ways as a couple, but look forward
to continuing our cherished friendship."
But don't feel too bad for Theroux.
He appears to be doing well following the
"heartbreaking" breakup, and he has at least
one major acting gig on the horizon.
In July 2018, Collider announced that Theroux
would be voicing the character of Tramp in
Disney's remake of Lady and the Tramp.
As for Lady?
She'll reportedly be voiced by Thor: Ragnarok's
Tessa Thompson.
Who would have guessed that Evil DJ would
wind up working for the House of Mouse?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.